as you do it please do it quickly it's
just going to save another life this is
the current drinking water to the ice
feels too dirty a poor hands and
shocking then I am so touched on the
street ha ha ha
speechless I'm speechless tomorrow we
should have clean water in a world war
[Music]
for today I have blessed gold what I
have done in my life I didn't know that
we can meet you and me we can't admit
but the quad knows what I have done for
you and me 20 players you yeah
I'm suffering no house know what you
have got Daniel good job me wise your
God then good job my dear animal Anka
buddy with hi my name is Samuel leaves
and in 48 hours time I will be on a
plane on my way to Uganda Africa I'm
going to be doing some charity work out
there now many of you that know me well
will know that me and my wife we go out
once sometimes twice a year and we spend
a few weeks in different parts of Africa
so usually Zambia or Zimbabwe we've done
work in Kenya Tanzania this time Uganda
and the world that we do out there it's
it for me it keeps me motivated all
through the rest of the year to do what
I'm doing
within the business some of the stuff
that we do is simple such as 50 pounds
or a hundred and fifty pounds just a
small token and we'll give it to
somebody who has absolutely nothing and
take them shop it and the things that
they spend it on is heartbreaking and
humbling but it's just incredible and
then we go right for you to do some
really big stuff like we'll build a a
well will construct a borehole in a
village well have no water and currently
the kids are missing the time off school
to walk three miles a day to drink out
of the dirty stream and then get ill and
we'll just construct a well into one of
these villages and it will provide clean
fresh spring water for a village of
about
three or four hundred people and those
wells last years and years in years and
they were between helping widows start
up businesses because to support their
children because their husbands have
died working in orphanages and bringing
clothes and food to the orphans it's
just fantastic but the reason for this
video is really just a shower will be
documenting some of the stuff if you go
on to my facebook page you'll probably
see some of the videos that we've done
in the past there was a video that
almost went viral about a lady who we
gave 50 pounds to and she went and spent
it on her orphaned children she had an
orphanage and she spent it on them and
it was just incredible but I'll give you
guys a chance to donate because I'm
going to be there in Uganda but if you
wanna if you want to give and want to
see us spend a little video it will
document it and we'll send you back the
results and you will be touched and
moved at the house such small things can
go such a long way here's what I'm
proposing anywhere between 50 pounds and
150 pounds what we'll do with your gift
by the way a hundred percent of your
money will go on the project okay not
going to cover my fights or anything
like that just for the record I don't
need your money but they do okay
so 150 pounds 150 pounds will go towards
that will be a surprise gift for someone
who has nothing more video in their
reaction and will video than spending it
anywhere between one hundred and fifty
pounds to five hundred pounds that's
going to go to helping a widow with her
business because there's a lot of widows
that are forced to have to look after
their children and fetch all the water
and everything but also they're forced
have to be an entrepreneur and go out
and sell products in the streets and
stuff to live so one of the things that
we do is we just support and sometimes
by maybe buying them a load of stock and
give them some business training or
whatever we might be but 150 to 500 will
be supporting a widow support her
children and this really is the teacher
man to fish to its fullest and anywhere
between five hundred and two and a half
thousand
and that you donate that will go on an
orphanage project so feeding and
clothing orphans who are in an orphanage
so we'll work of the people that run the
orphanage and we'll allocate the spent
accordingly and so that it goes as far
as it possibly can
well video all the stuff that goes on in
the orphanage and we'll send that to you
a borehole to build and construct a well
for a village costs around about 5,000
pounds now if you want to just if you
want to just see a borehole construct it
and bring clean water to a whole village
you're very welcome to donate 5,000
pounds I do it regularly
we've done that many times we'll just
say boom and we'll and we'll donate it
and 5,000 pounds that that covers the
poems and the all the wall and we'll
drill down about 100 meters deep until
we hit fresh clean spring water which
will then spurt out for all the village
to come in and use and that will also
include as well sanitary education
classes so that will teach the people
how to use it and how to be clean and
everything like that if you'd like to
donate half the borehole that's two and
a half thousand pounds again that would
be a massive massive thing to do so and
wick you know anyone that donates a
borehole or half a borehole will take
out as well okay we'll do it and you are
very welcome to come out and see what
what what difference is made and I'm
sure it will bring you to tears I pretty
much break down at some point every time
we go so that's some of the options you
know if you're already giving if you're
already doing stuff then that's fine
this is not for you but if you feel like
you really want to give back and you
want to see some differences across the
world and help people that haven't
nothing then here's what portunity to do
that and I'll be very glad to partner
with you and go down and do what work
and put your money into that good use
so anyway god bless you and thank you
for watching this video and I look
forward to seeing you soon
wish me luck in Uganda the day after
and you very much thank you very much
thank you very much